Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I thank you, said the king, for that you have delivered into my hands one whom I had vowed to punish, in that he has caused us more scathe by fouler means than any living man. Twice have I sworn... I can't wait for the sentence, Dominic. How could he have written this without...
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。“国王说，我感谢你，因为你将此人交到了我手中，我曾发誓要惩罚他，因为他用比任何活人都更卑劣的手段给我们带来了巨大的灾难。我曾两次发誓……”多米尼克，我已经等不及要听判决了。他怎么能不经思考就写下……
Go on. Without actually laughing. I should explain to the listeners that this is about the tenth time Dominic has tried to read this. Come on. Okay, give us a sentence. Twice have I sworn that Peter the Red Ferret shall hang for all his noble blood and coat armour
继续。居然还能忍住不笑。我得跟听众们解释一下，这已经是多米尼克第十次尝试读这段了。行啦。好吧，给我们念一句。“我曾两次发誓，尽管彼得有着高贵的血统和纹章铠甲，
if ever he should fall into my hands. Now at last his time has come. Sire, murmured Nigel, it ill becomes me to cross your royal will. The dark, plantagenet wrath gathered upon the king's high brow and gloomed in his fierce, deep-set eyes. By God's dignity! No man has ever crossed it yet and lived unscathed. How now, young sir, what mean such words to which we are little want? Have a care, for this is no light thing which you venture. Nigel faced the
如果他落入我手中，红雪貂也难逃一死。如今他的死期终于到了。西尔，奈杰尔低声道，违背您的皇家意志实在不是我的本分。金雀花王朝阴暗的怒火在国王高高的额头上凝聚，在他那双凶猛深陷的眼中阴郁翻滚。凭着上帝的尊严！还从没有人敢违抗它而全身而退。怎么，年轻的先生，这些话是什么意思，我们对此可不习惯？当心点，你这可是冒天下之大不韪。”奈杰尔面对着
king with a face as grim as his own. You may not put to death the red ferret. Yeah. So that, Tom Holland, was a reading from Sir Nigel by Sir Arthur Conan Doyle. And what a treat for all the listeners that there are going to be two more of those. was a reading from Sir Nigel by Sir Arthur Conan Doyle.
国王，神情和他一样冷酷。“你不能处死红雪貂。”好啦。汤姆·霍兰，刚才那段是亚瑟·柯南·道尔爵士所著《奈杰尔爵士》（Sir Nigel）的朗诵。对于所有听众来说，接下来还会有另外两段，这可真是一大福利啊。刚才那是亚瑟·柯南·道尔爵士所著《奈杰尔爵士》的朗诵。
And what a treat for all the listeners that there are going to be two more of those. Does the Red Ferret appear in the next two as well? What, next week? Yeah. No, no, no. The Lord of Gros Bois appears. Listen, so that was the fate of the Red Ferret. There's a massive disagreement between Sir Nigel and the King, Edward III.
对于所有听众来说，接下来还会有另外两段，这可真是一大福利啊。红雪貂在接下来的两段里也会出现吗？什么，下周？对。不，不，不。格罗斯布瓦领主（Lord of Gros Bois）要登场了。听着，红雪貂的命运就是这样。奈杰尔爵士和国王爱德华三世之间产生了巨大的分歧。
Tom, you talked last time about how much you loved that book, Sir Nigel, when you were growing up. I can't believe that you're desecrating it with your laughter. Well, I know it's a whippled way. It is. Yes, it is poor. So we're talking about the Hundred Years' War. Last time you gave us, I thought, I suppose I'm biased because it's kind of my podcast, but I thought it was a brilliant summation of the causes of the hundred years war it's incredibly complicated
汤姆，你上次谈到你小时候有多么喜爱《奈杰尔爵士》这本书。我真不敢相信你竟然用笑声来亵渎它。好吧，我知道这有点滑稽。确实是。是的，确实挺逊的。所以我们正在讨论百年战争。上周你给我们做了一个——我觉得吧，也许是因为这是我的播客所以我有点偏心，但我觉得那绝对是一份对百年战争起因的精彩总结——这是一个极其复杂的故事，
story the relationship between france and england philip the sixth i think is philip the sixth isn't it um french king philip of valois yeah increasingly fat and depressed yeah but who has disgraced himself by his provocations against against the rightful king of France. Yeah, the gallant Edward III. Anyway, Edward III has launched this sort of slightly preemptive war, hasn't he? He's concerned about Scotland in the north. He's got France across the channel. You entered the last podcast by saying everybody in Europe basically thinks the English are going to lose. They're the massive underdogs. France is six times richer, many times larger, the home of chivalry, of gallantry, of the knightly code, all of that kind of business. How does Edward Tom think he's... I mean, what's his strategy?
法国和英国之间的关系，腓力六世，我想是腓力六世吧，呃，法国国王瓦卢瓦的腓力，对吧，变得越来越胖、越来越沮丧，对吧，但他因为对法国合法国王的挑衅而自取其辱。对，英勇的爱德华三世。总之，爱德华三世发动了这种有点先发制人的战争，不是吗？他担心北方的苏格兰。英吉利海峡对面就是法国。你在上期播客的结尾说，欧洲每个人基本上都认为英国人会输。他们是绝对的弱势方。法国的财富是英国的六倍，国土面积大得多，是骑士精神、风度以及骑士准则的发源地，诸如此类。爱德华·汤姆认为他该如何……我是说，他的战略是什么？
How is he going to play this? Well, he spells it out actually in a letter to the Pope, no less, which he writes a couple of years after the start of the war. And he says that his aim in fighting the war is we only make a shield against him who leveled a deadly blow at our head. So that's Philippe Valois. The best way to avoid the inconveniences of war is to pursue it away from one's own lands. It makes the best sense for us then to fight our enemy in his own realm, in alliance with the power of our allies, rather than to wait for him to batter down our front door. Okay. Yep.
他打算怎么打这场仗？好吧，他在一封写给教皇的信中明确阐述了这一点，而且就在战争爆发几年后写的。他在信中说，他打这场战争的目的是：“我们只是为自己打造一面盾牌，用来对付那个向我们的头部给予致命一击的人。”指的就是瓦卢瓦的腓力。“避免战争带来的麻烦的最好方法，就是将战争推向远离自己土地的地方。因此，在我们自己的领土上、在盟友力量的支援下与我们的敌人作战，对我们来说才是最明智的抉择，而不是坐在家里等着他来砸我们的前门。”好吧。没错。
So to do that, basically he has to prevent the French from landing in England. And so he has to win control of the seas, but that's a challenge because ships are very, very expensive. So ideally you'd be looking for a kind of knockout battle where you could perhaps demolish the French fleet. And actually the year before he wrote that letter to the Pope, there'd been a sign of how dangerous and precarious the situation is for England when the French, I mean, they burn Portsmouth to the ground. I think they leave a single church standing and then they attack Southampton. So this is a real danger for the English. And the other thing that he's saying is that he's going to attack France in alliance with the power of our allies. So he has these three kind of semi-independent realms in France. So there's Aquitaine, which he's defending.
所以为了做到这一点，基本上他必须阻止法国人在英国登陆。因此他必须赢得对海洋的控制权，但这挑战重重，因为军舰非常非常昂贵。所以最理想的情况是寻找一场决定性的海战，或许能借此摧毁法国舰队。事实上，就在他写那封信给教皇的前一年，发生了一件事，标志着英国的处境是多么危险和飘摇——当时法国人，我是说，他们把朴次茅斯烧成了平地。我想他们只留下一座教堂完好无损，然后他们又袭击了南安普顿。所以这对英国人来说是真正的威胁。他说的另一件事是，他要在盟友力量的支援下进攻法国。因此他在法国有三个半独立的地区。首先是阿基坦，这是他正在保卫的地方。
There's Brittany, where he has very kind of close allies. And then there's Flanders. And Flanders, of course, is the closest theatre of war to England. It's the easiest for him to get across to. And it's also France's richest province by far. And so by attacking that, he will force the French king to focus on that rather than attacking Gascony, which is a long way from Paris. And Edward, as his predecessors on the throne of England have understood, recognises that the key to winning Flanders over isn't necessarily to target the Count of Flanders,
其次是布列塔尼，在那里他有着非常亲密的盟友。最后是佛兰德斯。而佛兰德斯，当然是距离英国最近的战区。这是他最容易渡海过去的地方。同时它也是法国最富裕的省份，没有之一。因此通过进攻那里，他将迫使法国国王把注意力集中在佛兰德斯，而不是去进攻离巴黎很远的加斯科涅。爱德华和此前历代英格兰王位继承人一样，意识到赢得佛兰德斯人支持的关键，不一定是要针对佛兰德斯伯爵，
who's an ally of the French king, but to target the cities where the weavers live because they are dependent on the supply of French wool. So these are the Ghent and Bruges and Ypres and all these places? Yes. So 1337, Edward bans wool exports and this imposes massive strain on the various cities in Flanders. And by December 1337, basically, the whole of Ghent is in a state of revolution. And it's led by a guy called Jacob van Atevoldt, who is a merchant in Ghent. And he basically makes the economic case for allying with Edward. He says to his fellow weavers and merchants, without the goodwill of the King of England, we shall die. For Flanders lives by making cloth.
因为伯爵是法国国王的盟友，而是要针对织工们居住的城市，因为他们依赖法国羊毛的供应。所以这些城市就是根特、布鲁日、伊普尔和所有这些地方？是的。所以1337年，爱德华禁止出口羊毛，这给佛兰德斯的各个城市带来了巨大的压力。到了1337年12月，基本上整个根特都陷入了革命状态。这场革命由一个名叫雅各布·范·阿特费尔德（Jacob van Artevelde）的人领导，他是根特的一名商人。他从经济角度论证了与爱德华结盟的必要性。他对同行的织工和商人们说：“如果没有英格兰国王的善意，我们只有死路一条。因为佛兰德斯靠生产呢绒为生。
Cloth cannot be made without wool. It follows, therefore, that we must make a friend of England. And the other leading cities in Flanders say Bruges and Ypres. I mean, they all hate each other, but on this they agree. And they basically say, the cities, that they will be neutral in the coming conflict. And Jonathan Sumption, in the first volume of his immense history of the Hundred Years' War, describes this as one of the few examples in history of a wholly successful economic blockade. So it has exactly the results that Edward wants. And Edward is hopeful that things might go even further because van Artevelde is
没有羊毛就织不出呢绒。因此，顺理成章地，我们必须与英格兰交朋友。”佛兰德斯的其他主要城市，比如布鲁日和伊普尔也表态了。我是说，它们平时互相看对方不顺眼，但在这件事上它们达成了一致。这些城市基本上表示，它们将在即将到来的冲突中保持中立。乔纳森·萨姆森（Jonathan Sumption）在其皇皇巨著《百年战争史》第一卷中，将此描述为历史上绝无仅有的“完全成功的经济封锁”的范例之一。因此它取得了爱德华想要的完全相同的效果。爱德华希望事情能进展得更顺利，因为范·阿特费尔德
quite keen actually to have an open alliance with England. But the problem with that is that if the various Flemings do row in openly behind Edward, then that puts them in breach of their oaths of loyalty to the French throne. So what's the way around that? Well, the obvious way around that is for Edward to lay claim to the French throne. Oh, because then they're not... So they take their oaths so seriously because they've sworn them in the Bible or something. Yes, they do take it seriously. Yeah, well, they'd risk excommunication. Right. So Edward isn't yet ready openly to declare himself King of France.
其实非常渴望与英格兰建立公开的同盟关系。但问题在于，如果佛兰德斯的各个城市公开倒向爱德华，那么这就违背了他们对法国王室效忠的誓言。那解决这个问题的办法是什么呢？显而易见的办法就是由爱德华对法国王位提出主权声索。哦，因为这样一来他们就不是……他们把誓言看得这么重，是因为他们是在圣经上发过誓之类的吗？是的，他们确实非常重视。对，好吧，他们会面临被逐出教会的风险。没错。所以爱德华当时还没准备好公开宣布自己是法国国王。
But in the spring of 1338, he sends ambassadors to Paris where he addresses Philip VI, not as a king, but as Philip of Valois, and delivers a formal announcement that Edward is intending to conquer our inheritance, so France, by our force of arms. But it's so interesting that that's a tactic in the war rather than the reason for which the war is fought. It is. It's a symptom of war rather than a cause. Right. Okay.
但在1338年春，他派遣大使前往巴黎，在那里他称呼腓力六世的头衔不是国王，而是瓦卢瓦的腓力，并正式宣布爱德华打算以武力“征服我们的遗产”，也就是法国。但非常有趣的是，这只是战争中的一种策略，而不是发动战争的真正原因。确实如此。这更像是战争的一个症状，而不是起因。没错。好吧。
Absolutely. But of course, Edward faces this problem that England compared to France is very, very puny. And his strategy basically requires him to... There are four theatres of war. So there's Scotland, the Scots are misbehaving up in the north. There's the south coast of England. So that's getting raided all the time. There's Gascony, of course, that needs defending. And now he's opened up this fourth front in Flanders. And this needs money. And so Edward borrows vast, vast amounts from various Italian banks and he also borrows vast amounts from the various cities in Flanders. And the cities in Flanders knows that Edward, basically Edward can only pay them back if he starts winning storming victories in France. And they demand a surety that Edward crosses to Flanders and stays there. And so he does that. He victories in France. They demand austerity that Edward crosses to Flanders and stays there. He does that. He invades northern France in 1339. He's trying
完全正确。但当然，爱德华面临着这样一个问题：与法国相比，英格兰实在太微不足道了。他的战略基本上要求他……有四个战区。首先是苏格兰，苏格兰人在北方作乱。其次是英格兰南部海岸。那里的海岸线经常遭到袭击。再次是加斯科涅，当然，那里需要防守。现在他又在佛兰德斯开辟了第四个战线。这需要资金。于是爱德华从各大意大利银行借了巨额资金，他还向佛兰德斯的各个城市借了巨额资金。而佛兰德斯的城市深知，爱德华基本上只有在法国取得势如破竹的胜利后才能还钱。他们要求获得担保，即爱德华要亲自渡海去佛兰德斯并在那里待下去。于是他这么做了。在法国取得了胜利。他们要求获得担保，即爱德华要亲自渡海去佛兰德斯并在那里待下去。他真的这么做了。他在1339年入侵了法国北部。他试图
to provoke Philip into battle. Philip doesn't take the bait. Basically, by January 1340, Edward is really facing problems because his debts are just piling up. He's stuck in Flanders. Back in England, Parliament's becoming very resentful because Edward is demanding that they vote him more money and it just seems to be a kind of bottomless hole. There's popular resentment in England. People are starting to write abusive poems about him and about the war. And so Edward, to try and kind of rally the cause, in January, he openly declares himself King of France. And he is backed in this throne by the Count of Hainaut, who is the father of his queen, Philippa, and by Ghent and all the various cities in Flanders. But in England, it's very unpopular because the English don't like the
激怒腓力出来应战。腓力没有上钩。基本上到了1340年1月，爱德华真的面临大麻烦了，因为他的债务如滚雪球般越积越多。他被困在佛兰德斯。而在英国国内，议会变得非常怨声载道，因为爱德华要求他们投票表决拨付更多资金，这看起来就像是个无底洞。英国国内出现了民怨。人们开始写讽刺诗来攻击他和这场战争。因此，为了重振士气，爱德华在1月公开宣称自己是法国国王。他的这一王位诉求得到了埃诺伯爵（Count of Hainaut）的支持，埃诺伯爵是他妻子菲利帕的父亲，同时他也得到了根特和佛兰德斯各个城市的拥护。但在英国，这非常不得人心，因为英国人并不喜欢
idea of their king becoming King of France. So it's not a rallying cry. Because they think they'll be relegated. Yeah, they do. And so Edward realizes that he's got a real problem in England. And so basically, he's got to go back to England to sort it out. And the Flemish cities impose really humiliating terms on him. So he's able to go back, but he has to leave hostages, including several of his leading nobles. But also Philippa, his wife, his queen. And this is when she gives birth to her third son, who is called John in Ghent, which is why he comes to be called in due course, John of Ghent, i.e. John of Gaunt.
他们的国王变成法国国王的想法。所以这根本没法提振士气。因为他们觉得自己的地位会被降级。对，他们的确这么想。因此爱德华意识到他在国内遇到了真正的麻烦。所以基本上，他必须回英国去把事情理顺。而佛兰德斯的城市向他提出了极其屈辱的条件。于是他得以返回，但必须留下人质，包括他几位最重要的贵族。还有他的妻子菲利帕王后。正是在这个时候，她在根特生下了她的第三个子嗣，在根特被称为约翰，这就是为什么他后来顺理成章地被称为“根特的约翰”（John of Ghent），也就是冈特的约翰（John of Gaunt）。
So he'll become a kind of famous player. I never knew that, Tom. Yeah. So that's the reason. I've really learned something tremendous. John of Gaunt is actually John of Ghent. Yes. So that's where that comes from. Crikey. So basically, Edward is facing the collapse of his entire strategy because he can't afford it. And you might think that this would be enough to bring him to terms, but he's still absolutely determined to carry on the war. He's still absolutely determined that
所以他日后会成为一个大名鼎鼎的人物。我以前真不知道这个，汤姆。是的。所以这就是原因所在。我真的学到了一条了不得的冷知识。冈特的约翰实际上就是根特的约翰。是的。名字就是这么来的。天哪。所以基本上，爱德华正面临着他整个战略的崩溃，因为他已经无力承担了。你可能会觉得这足以迫使他妥协了，但他仍然坚决要继续这场战争。他依然坚决认为
he's got the right strategy. And what are the reasons for this? Well, I mean, there is no disputing the fact that he is probably the biggest lad ever to have sat on the throne of England. I mean, he's very, very good at certainly getting his immediate circle on his side. And indeed, this is why he goes back to England, because he's confident that his kind of glamour, his charisma will succeed in winning his subjects back to his cause. So just for the listeners' benefit benefit he's about 26 27 at this point i think he turns 27 in 13 39 or so so he's a he's still he's absolutely in the prime of life yeah serial tournament winner yeah lover of gallantry all that kind of stuff he's got this sort of jfk style glamour i guess well our theory and glamour because it is camelot i mean it's
他的战略是正确的。那么原因何在呢？好吧，也就是说，毫无争辩的事实是，他可能是坐上英国王位个头最大、最威猛的小伙子。我是说，他在让自己核心圈子的人站在自己这一边方面非常非常在行。事实上，这也是他返回英国的原因，因为他坚信自己的个人魅力、他的个人磁性能够成功地让他的子民重新支持他的事业。所以为了听众们的福利——福利就是他当时大概26、27岁吧，我想他在1339年左右迎来了27岁生日，所以他正值人生的绝对巅峰时期。没错，连胜的锦标赛冠军，没错，风流倜傥的化身，诸如此类。他身上有那种类似肯尼迪式的魅力，我想。好吧，亚瑟王式的魅力，因为这就是卡米洛特式的风格——我是说，
overtly camelot so i mean shortly after he's overthrown Mortimer, who'd been blocking the throne for him, he goes to Glastonbury to pay his respects to the tomb of Arthur. And the various lads, his friends who had helped him to overthrow Mortimer, are kept around him rather in the way that Arthur keeps the Knights of the Round Table around him. And in 1337, when the war begins, he elevates six of them. He makes them earls. So the one who will become the most famous is the fifth son of the Earl of Hereford. So very low down the pecking order for that family. But he's created the Earl of Northampton. And it's very much the idea that you get in Shakespeare's Henry V, where he talks of we few, we happy few, we band of brothers. This is what Edward III is all about. But as you said, he's also very, very good at dazzling his people with tournaments and all the kind of Camelot stuff. So that's great strategic genius in the Hundred Years' War. His strategy is right. And even though he's got money problems, he's right that denying the French access to the Channel ports, which is what the alliance with Flanders has brought him, is really key. Because that means that basically the English are safe from invasion. So that's its first target. But on top of that, he has, I mentioned
这完全就是卡米洛特。所以——在他推翻了曾阻挠他继承王位的莫蒂默（Mortimer）不久后，他前往格拉斯顿伯里（Glastonbury）向亚瑟王的陵墓致敬。他身边的那些年轻伙伴、帮他推翻莫蒂默的随从们都一直留在身边，就像亚瑟王将圆桌骑士留在身边一样。1337年战争爆发时，他晋升了其中的六个人。他封他们为伯爵。其中最著名的要数赫里福德伯爵（Earl of Hereford）的第五子。在该家族的继承序列中排名非常靠后。但他被册封为北安普顿伯爵（Earl of Northampton）。这非常符合莎士比亚《亨利五世》中的那种理念，里面提到“我们少数人，我们这些幸运的少数人，我们这群生死兄弟”。这就是爱德华三世的作风。但正如你所说，他也非常擅长用比武大会和各种卡米洛特式的派头来让他的子民眼花缭乱。所以这是百年战争中的伟大战略天才。他的战略是正确的。尽管他有资金问题，但他对 denying（剥夺）法国人使用海峡港口的权利是正确的，而这正是与佛兰德斯的同盟带给他的优势，这绝对是关键。因为这意味着基本上英国人免受了入侵的威胁。所以这是他的第一个目标。不仅如此，正如我
at the end of the last episode, he has a secret weapon. And this secret weapon is the longbow, which is a word that is kind of brought into common usage over the course of the 14th into the 15th century to describe a specifically English bow that is about the height of a man, maybe even higher when strung. And they're so long that they can accommodate kind of very, very long arrows because you can draw it all the way back to your ear. So that gives it much greater velocity. And Dominic, I'm afraid that I have to introduce some maths at this point. Maths. This is a first in the rest of history. Yeah. So I'm going to read a sentence from an essay by Clifford Rogers, who brilliantly is professor
在上集结尾时提到的，他拥有一个秘密武器。这个秘密武器就是长弓（longbow）。这个词在14世纪到15世纪期间逐渐普及开来，用来描述一种特有的英国弓，它大约有一个成年人的身高，如果张弦的话甚至比人还要高。它们非常长，因此可以容纳非常非常长的箭，因为你可以把弦一直拉到耳边。这就赋予了它极大的初速。多米尼克，恐怕我这时候得引入一些数学知识了。数学。这在《历史的余烬》里可是破天荒头一遭。没错。所以我要读一段克利福德·罗杰斯（Clifford Rogers）的文章中的句子，他非常了不起，是美国西点军校——也就是那座军事学院——的中世纪历史学教授。所以他对兵器非常感兴趣。他说，这些弓异乎寻常的厚度至关重要，因为直弓的拉力与它厚度的立方成正比。
of medieval history at West Point, the military academy in the United States. So very interested in weaponry. And he says that the exceptional thickness of these bows is crucial because the draw strength of a straight bow rises proportionally with the cube of its thickness. So that, for example, 30% greater thickness equates to 120% more power. Did you understand that? I did. I followed that very closely. So they're very long and thick bows, basically. And incredibly powerful. So they have incredible penetrative power and they can penetrate through chain mail. And that's the key thing.
打个比方，厚度增加30%，意味着威力会增加120%。你听懂了吗？我听懂了。我跟得很紧。所以基本上它们就是又长又厚的弓。而且威力惊人。所以它们具有无与伦比的穿透力，能够射穿锁子甲。这才是关键所在。
So obviously people had bows before. But you're telling me that all the bows that people had previously employed from the Romans through to the Franks, to the Normans and so on, this had not occurred to people before to have bows of such size. Well, there is controversy around this. It probably won't surprise you to learn that there are revisionists who claim that actually the longbow is nothing, that it's just another word for bows that already existed. But I think that's improbable, both because the word longbow does get introduced because of the impact that it has. And also because you do at the beginning of the 14th century, you start to get both manuscripts and illustrations that are referring to bows that are clearly longbows. So the earliest manuscript to show a longbow is about 1305.
显然，以前的人们也有弓。但你的意思是，从罗马人到法兰克人、再到诺曼人等等，此前人们使用的所有弓，以前从来没有人想过制造这种尺寸的弓吗？好吧，关于这一点存在争议。你可能不会感到意外，有一些历史修正主义者声称，长弓其实没什么大不了的，它只是以前就存在的那些弓的另一个名字而已。但我认为这不太可能，一方面是因为“长弓”这个词确实由于它带来的巨大影响而被引入了词汇库；另一方面是因为在14世纪初，你确实开始看到手稿和插图明确提到了很明显就是长弓的武器。所以最早展示长弓的手稿大约绘制于1305年。
The first document that unambiguously describes a longbow, it's in a murder indictment that can be dated very precisely to the 4th of July, 1313. And so what that suggests is that I had always thought, this is what I read when I was a child with my Hundred Years War Obsession, that Edward I had always thought, this is what I read when I was a child with my 100 Years War obsession, that Edward I had picked it up from Welsh fighters in his wars against the Welsh. Because the Welsh are very famous because of Agincourt and whatnot. But it turns out that this seems not to be the case. It basically seems to have been invented in the first decades of the 14th century, and it seems to have been targeted against the Scots. So it may be that
而第一份明确描述长弓的文件，则是一份可以追溯到1313年7月4日的谋杀案起诉书。所以这表明——我以前一直以为，这是我小时候痴迷百年战争时读到的——爱德华一世是从他在对威尔士战争中的威尔士战士那里学来的这一招。因为威尔士人因阿金库尔战役等等而闻名遐迩。但事实证明似乎并非如此。它基本上似乎是在14世纪的前几十年里被发明的，而且它似乎一开始就是针对苏格兰人的。所以这可能是
it's a response to Edward II's war going badly against the Scots, Bannockburn and the aftermath of that, an attempt by the English to basically consciously develop a weapon that will enable them to redress the balance of war. And certainly at the Battle of Halland and Hill, which is where Edward III wins his first great victory against the Scots outside Berwick. Henry of Huntingdon, the chronicler, specifies that it's the ability of English archers to penetrate mail that comes as a shock to the Scots and basically kind of leads to their route. The sense that this is something new. And so I think that we did an episode on Trafalgar, and the whole thing about Trafalgar was that Nelson could be confident that his mastery of naval warfare was in every way superior to that of the French and Spanish. That the Royal Navy's ability to inflict carnage on their enemies was quantitatively greater, qualitatively greater.
对爱德华二世在与苏格兰人的战争中失利的一种回应，比如班诺克本战役及之后的余波，这是英国人蓄意开发一种能够扭转战争均势的武器的尝试。而且毫无疑问，在哈利登山战役（Battle of Halidon Hill）中——那是爱德华三世在特威德河畔贝里克外取得的对苏格兰人的第一场重大胜利——编年史家亨廷顿的亨利（Henry of Huntingdon）明确指出，正是英国弓箭手穿透锁子甲的能力让苏格兰人感到震惊，并基本上导致了他们的溃败。这种感觉表明这是一种全新的事物。我想我们曾做过一期关于特拉法尔加海战的节目，特拉法尔加海战的全部意义就在于，纳尔逊能够确信他在海战方面的造诣在各方面都远超法西联合舰队。英国皇家海军对敌人大肆杀戮的能力在数量上更胜一筹，在质量上也更胜一筹。
And this essentially is what Edward III also has. He has a military technology that he knows that if he can bring it to bear on his enemy, he can essentially annihilate them. And this is in the context of medieval warfare is very unusual. Very, very decisive battles in the Middle Ages are rare. So Hastings stands out precisely because it is so unusual. It's the exception that proves the rule. So Edward's aim is very radical. And there's a kind of pleasingly Nelsonian quality to his first great victory in the Hundred Years' War, which is that it comes actually not on land, but at sea. In June 1340, he's brought the news that a great French fleet has descended on Flanders. It's enemy territory to the King of France. It's anchored in the mouth of the River Svin, which is opposite the port of Sluis, which today is landlocked
这本质上也就是爱德华三世所具备的优势。他拥有这样一种军事技术：他知道只要能将其应用到敌人身上，他基本上就能将对方彻底消灭。这在中世纪战争的语境下是非常罕见的。中世纪极具决定性的战役是少之又少的。所以黑斯廷斯战役之所以脱颖而出，恰恰是因为它如此罕见。它是证明这条规则的特例。因此，爱德华的目标是非常激进的。他的百年战争中的第一场重大胜利带有某种令人愉悦的纳尔逊式的特质，因为这场胜利其实不是在陆地上取得的，而是在海上。1340年6月，他得到消息称，一支庞大的法国舰队已经压境佛兰德斯。对于法国国王来说，这是敌占区。它抛锚停泊在兹温河（River Svin）口，正对着斯鲁斯（Sluis）港，如今由于河口淤积，那里已经成了内陆。
because of the estuaries silted up. Back then, it's a major port. Edward has brought this news, and he promptly empties all the harbours across England of shipping. He packs these ships with infantrymen, so men-at-arms, but above all with longbowmen. And he sails for Sluice. And when the French had brought news of this, they decided that they're going to adopt a defensive strategy. And so they draw their ships up in three lines and they've got some absolutely massive ships. One of which is Edward's flagship, which had been captured. So very humiliating for Edward. And they put them in the front row, and then they chain them up, and then they put another line, and then another line. And the aim with this is to create a kind of absolutely impassable barrier so that the
但在当年，那可是一个主要港口。爱德华得到这个消息后，立刻清空了英格兰各大港口的船只。他在这些船上塞满了步兵，也就是重装骑士，但最主要的是塞满了长弓手。然后他扬帆驶向斯鲁斯。当法国人得到这个消息时，他们决定采取防御战略。于是他们将船只排成三列，并且拥有一些体型极其庞大的巨舰。其中一艘就是爱德华的旗舰，之前被俘虏了。这对爱德华来说极其耻辱。他们把这些大船放在最前排，然后用铁链把它们锁在一起，接着排上第二列，然后是第三列。这样做的目的是构筑一道绝对无法逾越的屏障，好让
English can't force it. But Edward has the advantage that is provided for him by his longbowmen. So the English fleet closes in on the French lines, which are absolutely immobile. And the French have crossbowmen. So the crossbows are kind of mechanical, have bolts, very powerful, but are very slow to load and can't fire as far as the longbow, as it turns out. So essentially, they can't reach the English ships, but the English ships with their archers can reach the French ships. And this kind of rain of death descends
英国人无法强行突破。但爱德华拥有长弓手为他带来的绝对优势。因此，英国舰队逼近了纹丝不动的法国舰队。法国人装备了弩。弩是一种机械武器，发射弩矢，威力很大，但装填速度非常慢，而且射程不如长弓。事实证明，它们根本够不到英国船只，但带有弓箭手的英国船只却能攻击法国船只。这种“死亡之雨”倾泻在
on the french a contemporary who saw it says that it was like hail in winter just on the longbows tom can i ask you a quick question about the longbows so the people on um they are trained longbowmen they've been training at home yeah and the bows fame i mean the story is always that they're made of you is that is that right That they're made of you? And they are literally the height of a man. So they're like five foot 10, six foot or whatever it might be. And why is it that other people haven't copied the English? So for example, why don't the French have longbows? Because there seems to be a technology that is distinctive to the English. They've developed it in the north of England. They haven't yet had a chance to unleash it and to demonstrate what it can do. So the French don't even know what's coming? They don't really know what's
法国人头上。一位目击者形容说，当时的情景就像冬天的冰雹一样。汤姆，关于长弓，我能问你一个简单的问题吗？上面的那些人，他们都是训练有素的长弓手吗？他们一直在家里训练，对吧？而且关于弓的传闻，大家的说法一直都是它们是用紫杉木（yew）制作的，是这样吗？它们是用紫杉木制作的？而且它们真的跟一个成年人一样高。所以大约有五英尺十英寸、六英尺或者差不多这样。为什么其他人没有效仿英国人呢？比如，为什么法国人不配备长弓呢？因为这似乎是一种英国人独有的技术。他们在英格兰北部开发了这种技术。他们还没来得及将其释放并展示它的威力。所以法国人甚至不知道将要面对什么？他们根本不知道将要
coming. And on top of that, I think that one of the reasons why the English king and the English nobility are so invested in using infantry as opposed to cavalry, which is the way that traditionally knights display their chivalric prowess, is that they've suffered the humiliation of the Battle of Bannockburn and defeat at the hands of Scottish infantrymen. So the lesson that they have learned from their defeat in the Scottish Wars of Independence is that infantry, and particularly archers, can defeat charging cavalry. So this is a lesson that they have absolutely internalised. Whereas for the French, I mean, the very idea would be a kind of heresy. So they're just not prepared to grapple with it. And it's at the Battle of Sluice that they first demonstrate what can be done with this weapon.
面对什么。不仅如此，我认为英国国王和英国贵族之所以如此热衷于使用步兵而不是骑兵——传统上骑士是通过骑兵来展现其骑士风度的——其中一个原因在于，他们曾经遭受过班诺克本战役的奇耻大辱，并败在了苏格兰步兵手下。所以他们从苏格兰独立战争的失败中吸取的教训是，步兵、尤其是弓箭手，能够击败冲锋的骑兵。这绝对是他们铭刻在心的教训。然而对于法国人来说，这种想法简直就是一种异端邪说。所以他们根本不愿去正视它。正是在斯鲁斯战役中，他们第一次展示了这种武器的威力。
Because the reign of death that falls on the French at Sluice is such that by the time the English ships close in with the French ships and grapple them, people are dying all across the decks. And the men-at-arms can jump onto the French ships, clear them, seize them. And then the ships in the first line are so massive, so high, that the archers can then step onto them and just kind of rain death down on the other ships because the Flemings who are in alliance with the English, they see what's going on and they pour out a sleaze and they attack the French in the rear. And it's an absolute bloodbath. And the slaughter carries on well into the night and Edward's triumph is total. And Edward actually captures one of the admirals. The other two have died. And this is a guy who's been leading raids along the English coast. And so rather than ransom him, which is what convention would prescribe, Edward hangs him from the yardarm of his ship. That's a pretty bold statement. It is absolutely a bold statement, yeah.
因为倾泻在法国人头上的死亡之雨如此猛烈，以至于当英国船只贴近法国船只并与之贴身肉搏时，甲板上到处都是死伤的人。重装步兵可以跳上法国船只，将其清空并夺取。接着，第一排的船只体积如此庞大、船舷如此之高，以至于弓箭手可以登上这些大船，向其他船只倾泻死亡之雨，而与英国人结盟的佛兰德斯人也看清了局势，他们从斯鲁斯蜂拥而出，从背后攻击法国人。这简直是一场血腥大屠杀。这场大屠杀一直持续到深夜，爱德华取得了彻底的胜利。爱德华甚至俘虏了其中一名海军上将。另外两名已经阵亡了。这家伙此前一直在英国海岸线上进行劫掠。因此，爱德华没有索要赎金——按惯例本该如此，而是直接把他吊死在自己船只的横桁上。这可真是个极其大胆的表态。这绝对是个大胆的表态，没错。
Yes, it is. And what Edward is doing is marketing himself, not just as the leader of a terrifying war machine, but as a man who is prepared to inflict terrible punishment on his enemies. He's absolutely sending a marker. So that combined with the annihilation of the French fleet, I mean, Jonathan Sumption describes it, says that the French had suffered a naval catastrophe on a scale unequalled until modern times. I mean, so basically until the time of Nelson. Isn't there some tremendous story about the King's jester telling him the news or something? Yeah. So people are very nervous about telling Philip VI what has happened. And then the story
是的，确实如此。爱德华此举不仅是在把自己包装成一个令人恐怖的战争机器的领袖，更是向世人表明他准备对敌人施以极其严厉的惩罚。他绝对是在立规矩。因此，再加上对法国舰队的歼灭——我是说，乔纳森·萨姆森将其描述为“法国人在近代以前从未经历过、规模空前的海军灾难”。也就是说，直到纳尔逊时代之前都没有发生过。难道不是有一个非常精彩的关于国王的弄臣向他报告消息的故事吗？是的。当时人们都很害怕把发生了什么告诉腓力六世。然后传说
is that the jester is pushed into his presence and he cries out, oh, the cowardly English, the cowardly English. And then the king says, well, why were they cowardly? And the jester replies, they did not jump overboard like our brave Frenchmen. Tremendous stuff. And the corollary of this great victory is that it repairs Edward's prestige just when he needs it to be repaired. But at the same time, it gives the English control of the channel. And so therefore, Edward's strategy of taking the war to France is enormously facilitated because he can be confident now that the war won't come to England. So from this point onwards, he can hit the French at will, effectively, because he has control of the channel, right? I mean, this has completely changed the course of the war. Isn't there a claim, Tom, which I always enjoy, that the fish
一个弄臣被推到了他的面前，他大喊大叫道：“噢，懦弱的英国人，懦弱的英国人格外懦弱！”然后国王问：“好吧，他们为什么懦弱呢？”弄臣回答说：“因为他们没有像我们勇敢的法国人那样跳进海里。”真是精彩绝伦的故事。这场伟大胜利的随之而来的结果是，它在最需要的时候修复了爱德华的声望。但与此同时，这也让英国人控制了海峡。因此，爱德华将战争带到法国本土的战略得到了极大便利，因为他现在可以确信战争不会蔓延到英国本土。所以从这个时点开始，由于他掌控了海峡，他基本上可以随心所欲地打击法国人，对吧？我的意思是，这彻底改变了战争的进程。汤姆，难道没有这样一个我一直很喜欢的说法吗？当时斯鲁斯海战中的鱼
at Sluice had drunk so much French blood that if God had given them the power of speech, they would have spoken French. Oui, c'est vrai. Well, French fish, who'd have known it? Right, should we take a break, Tom? And then you can return by picking up the story after the Battle of Sluice, because I think we're heading
喝了太多法国血，以至于如果上帝赐予它们说话的能力，它们都会说法语了。Oui, c'est vrai（法语：是的，确实如此）。好吧，法国鱼，谁能想到呢？好了，汤姆，我们要不要休息一下？然后你可以在休息之后接着斯鲁斯战役的故事继续讲，因为我觉得我们接下来要讨论
for an even more exciting battle. Yeah, an even more crushing victory. The Battle of Crecy. This is a tremendous story. All right, we shall see you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. All right, we shall the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back to the rest is history uh you'll be relieved to hear there's no reading about the red ferret uh to queue up after the 27 takes that the initial reading took. But Tom, we ended last time by talking about the Battle of Sluice.
一场更加激动人心的战役了。没错，一场更具毁灭性的胜利。克雷西战役（The Battle of Crecy）。这是一个极其精彩的故事。好了，我们休息之后见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。好了，我们——the rest is entertainment.com，也就是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》，大家会松一口气地听到，在经历了最初录音时的27次试错后，这次不用再朗读关于红雪貂的段落了。不过汤姆，我们在上一节的结尾谈到了斯鲁斯战役。
Tremendous victory for Edward III. He has established this strategy of annihilation. He basically doesn't have the resources, does he, to do your traditional medieval war of kind of capturing a castle here, a castle there, bringing the enemy to terms. So what's his plan, would you say, from Sleuths onwards? I think his plan is a kind of force de frappe to corner the French army and to inflict such a devastating defeat on it that Philip will be brought to terms. So very like Nelson. I mean,
爱德华三世取得了巨大的胜利。他确立了这种歼灭战的战略。他基本上没有资源去打那种传统的、攻占这座城堡、攻克那座城堡、迫使敌人屈服的中世纪战争，对吧？那么从斯鲁斯战役之后，你认为他的计划是什么？我认为他的计划是一种“打击力量”（force de frappe），旨在逼入绝境法国军队，并给它造成毁灭性的打击，从而迫使腓力妥协。所以非常类似于纳尔逊。我是说，
it's a kind of Nelsonian strategy, only he wants to adopt it on land. But the problem is precisely that he does have to bring Philip to battle. And Philip is kind of wise to the dangers of that. And so basically there's a kind of dead lock and both sides are in a bad way. So Philip has lost the Battle of Sleaze. He's lost naval control of the channel. His lands have been wasted by Edward who keeps kind of marching in and burning everything. So he's really lost face. He's lost prestige. But Edward III, the Battle of Suisse doesn't help him with his finances. And so he actually ends up declaring bankruptcy and it precipitates the world's first great banking crash. So we've got all this kind of stuff at the moment with Credit Suisse and all that kind of thing. Deutsche Bank. Well, it was
这是一种纳尔逊式的战略，只不过他想在陆地上实施。但问题恰恰在于，他必须引诱腓力出来应战。而腓力对其中的危险心知肚明。所以基本上双方陷入了僵局，而且交战双方的处境都很糟糕。腓力输掉了斯鲁斯海战。他失去了对海峡的海上控制权。他的土地被不断行军并烧毁一切的爱德华蹂躏。所以他真的颜面扫地，威望扫地。然而对爱德华三世来说，斯鲁斯战役对他的财务状况毫无帮助。因此他最终宣布破产，并直接引发了世界历史上第一场大银行危机。所以我们最近也经历过瑞士信贷（Credit Suisse）和诸如此类的事情。德意志银行。好吧，其实是
Edward III who set off the first one. So yeah, two great Italian banks are kind of brought crashing down in ruin. And you get the first Italian contemporaries condemning the bankers for their greed and stupidity. It's the first case of this. But isn't this a foreshadowing of how the war will end, Tom? Because isn't this a classic case of one of those wars that um the french have so many more resources and really you know military historians would often say it's finance it's industrial capacity it's all these things that actually wins wars so you can fight against that for so long but you have to keep winning and winning and winning once
爱德华三世引发了第一场银行危机。所以，对，两家伟大的意大利银行在废墟中轰然倒塌。你还能听到第一代意大利同代人谴责银行家的贪婪与愚蠢。这还是头一遭。但这难道不是这场战争最终结局的某种预示吗汤姆？因为这难道不是那种经典战例吗？法国人拥有如此多的资源，真的，军事史学家通常会说，是财政、是工业产能、是所有这些因素最终赢得了战争。所以你可以对抗这种劣势很长时间，但你必须不断地赢、不断地赢、不断地赢。一旦
you start to lose yeah you know the front the french can afford to lose battles yeah and they're still in the game the english cannot really afford to lose battles, and they're still in the game. The English cannot really afford to lose any. And so Edward, despite his great victory at Sleaze, signs a truce with Philip. And again, he writes to the Pope saying, basically, I haven't got any money. It's the money that's the problem. But the war kind of rumbles on in the other great semi-independent fiefdom in France, which is Brittany. Because in May 1341, the Duke of Brittany dies
你开始失利，法国人输得起几场战役，因为他们依然留在牌局中。而英国人其实输不起任何一场战役，而他们也依然留在牌局中。英国人真的输不起任何一场。因此，尽管爱德华在斯鲁斯取得了伟大的胜利，他还是与腓力签署了休战协议。同样，他写信给教皇说，基本上，我没钱了。钱才是最大的问题。但战争在法国另一个半独立的封地——布列塔尼——继续断断续续地进行着。因为在1341年5月，布列塔尼公爵去世了，
and the succession is disputed. So there's his half-brother, John de Montfort, who is very pro-English, and his niece, Joan. And Philip VI takes the side of Joan, marries her to his nephew, who's a guy called Charles de Blois. And he summons John de Montfort, so the rival to paris under assurance of safe conduct and promptly arrests him which is not good behavior is it it's kind of what i expect from a french king there yeah but john de montford luckily has a tremendously cool wife lady de montford who bravely holds out um invites the english who comes sailing over edward iii comes across in person. Great success. So the
继承权引发了争端。争夺者有他的同父异母兄弟约翰·德·蒙福特（John de Montfort），他非常亲英；还有他的侄女琼（Joan）。瓦卢瓦的腓力六世支持琼，并将她嫁给了自己的侄子查尔斯·德·布卢瓦（Charles de Blois）。他以安全通行为由将约翰·德·蒙福特——也就是那个竞争对手——召至巴黎，并随即将其逮捕。这可真不是什么正人君所为，对吧？这确实是我对法国国王的一贯期待。但幸运的是，约翰·德·蒙福特有一个极其冷酷镇定的妻子蒙福特夫人（Lady de Montfort），她勇敢地坚守阵地，邀请英国人航海前来。爱德华三世亲自横渡海峡。大获成功。于是
Earl of Northampton, the guy who has been made an Earl by Edward back in 3037, he captures Brest. And that's absolutely key because that is a port that controls the headland of Brittany sticking out into the sea and thereby makes the sea route from England to Gascony and Bordeaux secure. So that's a great strategic success. And 1343, there's another treaty signed. And basically, things are starting to look up for Edward because he's now got his alliance in Flanders. He's got all kinds of footholds in Brittany. It's starting to look good. And he's starting to put flesh on the bones of his claim to be King of France. And he knows that the more successful he is, the likelier it is that Philip is going to have to
北安普顿伯爵——也就是1337年被爱德华册封为伯爵的那个人——攻占了布雷斯特。这绝对是关键所在，因为那是一个控制着布列塔尼伸入大海岬角的港口，从而确保了从英国到加斯科涅和波尔多海上航线的安全。所以这是一次巨大的战略成功。1343年，双方签署了另一项条约。基本上，爱德华的处境开始好转，因为他现在有了佛兰德斯的同盟。他在布列塔尼拥有了各种据点。局势开始变得大好。他开始为自己作为法国国王的声索增添实质内容。他知道自己越成功，当休战协议到期时——实际上休战协议在1345年到期——腓力就越有可能
meet him in battle when the truce ends, which it actually ends in 1345. So Edward repudiates it a year early. And he sends an army to Gascony, planning to lead another into Normandy, but the terrible storms and then everything goes tits up in Flanders because Van Artevelt, the merchant from Ghent, who's very much his right-hand man there, gets killed by a mob. So Edward has to go to Flanders to try and sort it out, which he does successfully. But it means that his invasion of Normandy is delayed for a year. So it's 1346 is the year where he decides that he's going to launch a full frontal invasion of France. And at this point, he's going to launch a full frontal invasion of France. And at this point, he's thinking one battle, use the longbows, beat Philip,
在战场上与他正面交锋。所以爱德华提前一年单方面撕毁了协议。他派了一支军队去加斯科涅，计划率领另一支军队开赴诺曼底，但可怕的风暴袭来，接着佛兰德斯局势彻底崩盘——因为他在当地最得力的助手、根特商人范·阿特费尔德被暴民杀害了。所以爱德华不得不前往佛兰德斯去收拾残局，他也确实成功了。但这导致他入侵诺曼底的计划被推迟了一年。所以1346年才是他决定对法国发动全面正面入侵的一年。而在此时，他决定发动对法国的全面正面入侵。在这一时间点上，他的盘算是打一场战役，用长弓击败腓力，
and the war is done and dusted. Yes. And so this is the largest expedition that he's organised. And whereas previously he'd been largely fighting using continental allies, so Flemings or allies from the German Empire or Bretons or whatever, with this one, the majority of his troops are going to be English. So he's taking the flower of English chivalry, but he's also taking a huge contingent of Longbow men and men at arms. And the aim is to inflict such damage on France that Philip will have no choice but to meet him in battle. So it's kind of all or nothing strategy. I mean, because England doesn't have the manpower of France, right? So if Edward loses, he can't go back and dredge up
然后这场战争就大功告成了。是的。所以这是他组织过规模最大的一次远征。在此之前，他基本上主要是依靠欧洲大陆的盟友作战，比如佛兰德斯人、德意志帝国的盟友或是布列塔尼人等等，但在这次远征中，他的主力军队大部分都将是英国人。所以他带上了英国骑士精神的精华，但他也带去了庞大的长弓手和重装步兵队伍。其目的是对法国造成如此巨大的打击，以至于腓力别无选择，只能在战场上与他正面对决。所以这是一种破釜沉舟的战略。我的意思是，因为英国的人力不如法国，对吧？所以如果爱德华战败了，他是无法回去搜刮出更多军队的。
another X thousand. So sorry, actually say X thousand. How many people are we talking about? Would you say by and large in these kinds of armies? Probably about 8,000 men. Right. Edward's leading about 8,000 men. Yeah. I mean, obviously the French will be able to muster vastly larger numbers, but Edward is relying on the fact that he's a better commander and that his men are better. But it is a huge gamble. I mean, not least because the risk of an English defeat is that Edward himself and he's taking his young son, Edward of Woodstock, the Prince of Wales, the man who in due course will come to be known as the Black Prince. So he's taking him as well. So if Edward, the Prince of Wales and the Flower of English Chivalry get taken prisoner, I mean, that will bleed England dry. So it's a huge high stakes gamble that he's taking,
又是好几千。非常抱歉，其实应该说几千。我们到底在说有多少人？如果你大致估算一下这类军队？大概有8000人。没错。爱德华统帅大约8000人。对。我的意思是，很显然法军能召集多得多的兵力，但爱德华依仗的是他是个更出色的统帅，而且他的手下也更精锐。但这绝对是一场巨大的赌博。我的意思是，不仅因为一旦英军战败，爱德华本人——而且他带上了他年轻的儿子、威尔士亲王伍德斯托克的爱德华，也就是日后被称为“黑太子”的那个人。所以他也把儿子带上了。因此，如果爱德华、威尔士亲王和英格兰骑士精神的精华被俘虏，那就意味着英格兰将元气大伤。所以这是一场风险极高的大赌博，
but he's prepared for it very, very comprehensively. So he's taking large numbers of arrows. And he's also, for the first time in a medieval campaign, taking field cannon. So he's got a hundred small cannon. Previously, they'd only ever been used in sieges. He's had powder prepared in the Tower of London, kept dry, brought with him. So it's all or nothing, basically. So they leave early July, 12th of July, they land in Normandy, actually next to the beach that in 1944 will be called Utah Beach. So great broad beach. The landing, unlike in 1944, is unopposed. They land on the beach. Edward knights his son, the Prince of Wales. So very, very powerful moment. And he brilliantly, he declares that he's launching this invasion, which is very sweet of him, out of compassion for the wretched fate of the people of France.
但他对此做了非常非常充分的准备。所以他带了大量的箭矢。而且，这也是中世纪战役中第一次带上野战加农炮。他带了一百门小型加农炮。在此之前，这些火炮只被用于攻城。他在伦敦塔准备好了火药，保持干燥，并随身带上了火炮。所以这基本上就是背水一战。因此他们在7月初出发，7月12日，他们在诺曼底登陆，具体地点就在1944年被称为犹他海滩的海滩旁。那是一片宽阔伟大的海滩。与1944年不同，这次登陆没有遇到抵抗。他们在海滩上登陆。爱德华册封他的儿子威尔士亲王为骑士。这是一个非常非常震撼的时刻。而且他非常聪明地宣布，他发起这场远征——这对他来说真是太体贴了——完全是出于对法兰西人民悲惨命运的同情。
Oh, he's doing it for compassionate reasons. He is. He's doing it to be kind. And so the moment he's landed, the English just start looting, burning, destroying everything in their path. So often the way, Tom, are people who proclaim their own kindness on social media. Yes. So he's doing it to be kind. And he just, he's, he just, he marches through.
哦，他是出于同情的原因才这么做的。他确实是。他是为了表现善良才这么做的。所以他一登陆，英格兰人就开始劫掠、焚烧、毁灭他们路径上的一切。汤姆，在社交媒体上标榜自己善良的人往往就是这个德行。是的。所以他这么做是为了表现善良。他只是……他一路推进。
I mean, Normandy is some of the richest arable land in France, burns it all. Yeah. And he embarks on what is called a chevauchée. And a chevauchée is basically lads on tour burning everything, kind of 15-mile band around the movement of the army. And he advances down the line of the River Seine, heading towards Paris, because he knows that heading for Paris, Philip won't be able to ignore that. So Philip is brought the news of this. And on the 22nd of July, he takes up the great royal standard, the Oriflame. And this is the marker of a French king who is taking war seriously. And at the same time, he sends messengers to Scotland
我的意思是，诺曼底是法国最肥沃的耕地之一，他把这一切都烧光了。是的。他开始进行所谓的“骑行劫掠”（chevauchée）。而骑行劫掠基本上就是小伙子们到处烧毁一切，在军队行进路线周围形成大约15英里宽的毁灭带。他沿着塞纳河顺流而下，直奔巴黎，因为他知道直奔巴黎的话，腓力是绝对无法忽视的。因此，这个消息传到了腓力耳中。在7月22日，他举起了伟大的王室军旗——“弗拉姆”（Oriflamme）。这是法国国王严肃对待战争的标志。与此同时，他派遣信使去苏格兰，
to summon David II, who's gone back to Scotland to invade Northumbria. So the weasel Scott in Henry V's words. He also summons troops from across France. While he's waiting for these troops to come, he orders all the bridges across the Seine to be cut so that Edward, who's on the south bank, is basically left with the choice of attacking Paris, which will be murderous because he doesn't have enough troops to get involved in street fighting in the city, or to retreat to Normandy, which would obviously be an enormous loss of face. However, Edward isn't going to adopt either policy because he's convinced that it should be possible to find a crossing. And so in that conviction, he carries along the Seine very, very pointedly burning and looting all the royal properties that he comes across and trying to find a bridging point.
召回大卫二世——大卫二世此前已经回了苏格兰——去入侵诺森布里亚。用亨利五世的话说，这就是个狡猾的苏格兰黄鼠狼。他还从全法国召集军队。在等待这些军队到来的同时，他下令砍断塞纳河上的所有桥梁，这样身处南岸的爱德华基本上就只有两个选择：要么进攻巴黎，这将会是一场血腥的灾难，因为他没有足够的军队去在城里进行巷战；要么撤回诺曼底，这显然会极大地丢面子。然而，爱德华并不打算采取这两种策略中的任何一种，因为他坚信一定能找到一个过河点。怀着这样的信念，他沿着塞纳河一路走去，非常刻意地焚烧和劫掠他所遇到的所有王室财产，并试图寻找一个过河的桥头堡。
So they arrive at Rouen and they find that the bridge has been lost there. And there, there is a tremendous display of English heroism from a man who is, do you know what he's called? Well, you do because you've got my names. Oh my word. He's called Sir Thomas Holland. He is. What are the chances? So this is one of the leading figures of English chivalry. All of these podcasts have been building up to this moment, Tom. So Sir Thomas Holland, he's standing by the ruined bridge at Rouen and he sees the French on the far side and he bellows at them over and over again, St. George for King Edward, which I think is admirable behaviour.
于是他们抵达了鲁昂，却发现那里的桥梁已经被毁了。在那里，一个男人展现出了令人惊叹的英格兰英雄主义气概，你知道他叫什么名字吗？好吧，你知道，因为你有我的名单。哦天哪。他叫托马斯·霍兰德爵士。他确实叫这个。这几率有多大？所以这是英格兰骑士精神的领军人物之一。汤姆，所有的这些播客都是为了铺垫这一刻。所以托马斯·霍兰德爵士，他站在鲁昂被毁的桥边，看到河对岸的法军，便一遍又一遍地向他们大吼：“为了爱德华国王和圣乔治！”，我觉得这举止令人钦佩。
Does he fight anybody? Well, he can't because he can't get at them because the bridge has been cut. Always the way with Tom Holland, all talk and no... No, no, Dominic, because you will see that Sir Thomas Holland acquits himself very, very well in due course. He could be. Anyway. If they ever do a hundred Years War film, Tom,
他跟人打仗了吗？好吧，他没法打，因为他根本够不到他们，桥已经被切断了。汤姆·霍兰德一贯如此，光说不练……不，不，多米尼克，因为你会看到托马斯·霍兰德爵士稍后表现得非常非常出色。他可能吧。不管怎样。如果他们拍摄一部关于百年战争的电影，汤姆，
it would delight you to know that he could be played by Tom Holland, the well-known Spider-Man. Or me. Well, or you, but are you not a little Tom Holland now? Or Tom Hollander. Maybe. Yes. Anyway, go on.
你一定会高兴地知道，他可以由那个著名的蜘蛛侠扮演者汤姆·霍兰德来扮演。或者我。好吧，或者你，但你现在难道不是有点像汤姆·霍兰德吗？或者是汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Hollander）。也许吧。是的。不管怎样，继续。
So the English, they continue going towards Paris, and they come to a place called Poissy, which is a few miles outside Paris. And the bridge there has been broken, but engineers inspect it and they tell Edward, actually, I think we can repair this. But this is very kind of on the bridge stuff because once they've done that, it will require English troops to cross it in the assurance that they will basically be sitting ducks as they cross it. So, very, very perilous. But the guy who steps up to the plate is the earl of northampton
于是英格兰人继续向巴黎前进，他们来到一个叫普瓦西（Poissy）的地方，那是巴黎郊外几英里的一个小镇。那里的桥已经断了，但工程师们检查后告诉爱德华：“说实话，我觉得我们能修复它。”但这简直就是在桥上玩命，因为一旦他们修好了，就需要英格兰士兵冒着成为活靶子的风险走过它。所以，这非常非常危险。但是挺身而出的人是北安普敦伯爵。
now the guy who was ennobled as a thank you yeah yeah his sort of pal his pal yeah and they they um they get over the crossing they engage the french in uh brutal hand-to-hand combat and they hold them back as the english managed to make a crossing. The English do indeed have many casualties, but not as many, it turns out, as the French, because all the holding force on the north side of the river are wiped out and Edward is able to get across. So this is a great moment and Edward now decides that he is going to head towards Pontier, which is the estate that is his inheritance as King of England. It's been confiscated by Philip, so it's been annexed. By going to it, Edward is basically making a statement that he is going to his own, but it is also land that he's familiar with.
就是那个因效忠而被册封为贵族的人，对，对，他的某种哥们儿，他的哥们儿。然后他们……他们成功渡过了河，与法军展开了残酷的残酷肉搏战，并在英格兰人设法渡河的同时挡住了法军。英格兰人确实伤亡惨重，但事实证明，伤亡没有法军那么大，因为北岸的所有阻击部队都被消灭了，爱德华得以成功渡河。所以这是一个伟大的时刻，爱德华现在决定前往蓬蒂厄（Pontieu），那是他作为英格兰国王所继承的领地。这片领地被腓力没收了，因此被吞并了。通过前往那里，爱德华基本上是在宣示他要拿回属于自己的东西，而且这也是他熟悉的一片土地。
So he knows the terrain there. The problem for him is that to get to Pontier, he has to cross another river, the Somme. And he gets to the banks of the Somme and he again discovers that Philip has destroyed all the bridges. However, there is a ford. So this is a place called Blanchetac, the white spot. And at low tide, it's Blanchetac because there's a white stone can be seen and you get across. And they get there and they discovered that it's guarded by 500 men at arms, by 3,000 Genoese crossbowmen. But again, Northampton steps up to the plate. So he takes 100 longbowmen, 100 men at arms across the estuary.
所以他熟悉那里的地形。对他的问题在于，要到达蓬蒂厄，他必须穿过另一条河——索姆河。他到达索姆河岸边时，再次发现腓力已经摧毁了所有的桥梁。然而，这里有一个浅滩。这是一个叫布朗什塔克（Blanchetaq）的地方，意为“白点”。在退潮时，这里之所以叫布朗什塔克，是因为可以看到一块白色的石头，从而可以涉水过去。他们到达那里后，发现这里有500名重骑兵和3000名热那亚弩手把守。但北安普敦再次挺身而出。于是他带着100名长弓手和100名重骑兵渡过了河口。
The longbowmen rain a fire on the French guarding the northern bank. More and more English pile up behind it, storm up, 2,000 Frenchmen killed, entire English army cross, just as the last Englishmen get to the north bank and the high tide makes the ford impassable. So it's kind of a bit like Moses crossing the Red Sea, that kind of thing. So again, Edward has made it across and he can now head into Pontieu, his own duchy, and he makes for the great forest of Crecy, where there is a position that will entirely suit the kind of battle that he wants to fight. Meanwhile, the French are coming on,
长弓手向防守北岸的法军倾泻箭雨。越来越多的英格兰人聚集在后面，发起冲锋，2000名法军被杀，整支英格兰军队全部过河，就在最后一个英格兰人到达北岸、涨潮使得浅滩无法通行的时候。所以这有点像摩西过红海那样的情形。因此，爱德华再次成功渡河，他现在可以前往他的领地蓬蒂厄了，他径直奔向克雷西大森林，那里有一个完全适合他想要进行的战斗的地形。与此同时，法军正在逼近，
chasing the whole time. So meanwhile, the French are crossing the Somme and news is brought to Philip that Edward and the English have stopped at this hill by the forest of Cressy, about 10 miles to the north, and the French start to move towards it. And Edward has drawn up his men in three lines, so his knights and his men-at-arms. So about 8,000 to 10,000 men in total. So the first line, the first battalion, is commanded by the Prince of Wales. Who's 16.
一直在紧追不舍。与此同时，法军正在渡过索姆河，消息传到腓力耳中，称爱德华和英格兰人停在了大约10英里以北、克雷西森林旁的山丘上，法军开始向那里移动。爱德华将他的士兵排成了三个方阵，包括他的骑士和重骑兵。总共大约有8000到10000人。所以第一线、第一营由威尔士亲王指挥。他才16岁。
Who is 16. And so he has a man with a wiser head by his side. Oh, no. That man, Dominic, is Sir Thomas Holland. But of course. It's good of you to be in the front row, Tom. Yeah, I'm there. The second one is commanded by Northampton.
他才16岁。所以他身边有一个更有智慧的长者辅佐。哦，不。那个长者，多米尼克，就是托马斯·霍兰德爵士。理所当然。汤姆，你能坐在第一排真是不错。对，我就在那儿。第二线由北安普敦指挥。
Right. Who's done tremendous service already. And the third is commanded by Edward III. Yeah, who's commanding the reserves, basically, is he? Yeah. And Edward puts the archers and the cannon. You know, the French have no idea that the English have brought cannon with them because they've been strapped underneath the underside of the wagons.
没错。他已经立下了汗马功劳。第三线由爱德华三世指挥。是的，他基本上是指挥预备队，对吗？是的。爱德华把弓箭手和加农炮放在两翼。你知道，法军根本不知道英格兰人把加农炮带来了，因为它们被绑在辎重车的底部。
But the powder's been kept dry. The cannon are there. So archers and cannon are put in two great kind of clumps on either wing. And the archers dig holes and the archers dig trenches with spikes in front of them. And they put the wagons of the wagon train in front to create a kind of barrier between them and the French forces. And it's a very, very strong position. And Philip arrives on the morning of the 26th of August, and he recognizes that it's a strong position. And it's exactly the kind of battle that until now he has refused
但火药一直保持干燥。加农炮就在那里。所以弓箭手和加农炮被分成两大簇放置在两翼。弓箭手挖了洞，并在身前挖了带有尖桩的战壕。他们把辎重车队的货车挡在前面，在自己和法军之间建立起某种屏障。这是一个非常非常坚固的阵地。腓力在8月26日早晨抵达，他认出这是一个坚固的阵地。这正是他直到现在一直拒绝加入的那种战斗。
to join. But he also knows that he just can't afford the loss of face that would result from refusing Edward the battle. And even though there are lots in his council of war who urge him to do precisely that, he decides that they will fight and that they will wait for the late afternoon so that as many people who are coming to join him can arrive, but that they will fight it that day. And so he likewise draws his men up in three divisions. He's got about 25,000 men. So more than double. It's about three times the size. Yeah. Three times the size of the English army. So he puts his Genoese crossbowmen at the front and the Genoese crossbowmen normally would have kind of wicker shields
但他同时也知道，如果拒绝与爱德华交战，他将承担不起由此带来的丢脸后果。尽管他的作战会议上有很多人极力劝阻他这么做，但他还是决定要开战，并且决定等到下午晚些时候，以便尽可能多前来汇合的军队能够赶到，但他一定要在当天开战。于是他也将部队排成三个师。他大约有25000人。所以超过了两倍。大约是英格兰军队的三倍大小。是的。英格兰军队的三倍。所以他把热那亚弩手放在最前面，而热那亚弩手通常会配备某种柳条盾，
that they would put up and fire from behind the shields. But these are left behind in the baggage train that hasn't yet arrived. So they are without their protection. And they are commanded by John, who is the blind king of Bohemia, who we mentioned in the first episode. Tom, I'll say it right now. Madness to have a blind man. I don't want to be ableist,
他们会竖起盾牌并从盾牌后方射击。但这些盾牌落在了尚未到达的辎重车队里。所以他们没有了防护。他们由波希米亚的盲眼国王约翰指挥，我们在第一集里提到过他。汤姆，我现在就要说：让一个瞎子来指挥简直是疯了。我不想表现得对残疾人不敬，
but I wouldn't put a blind man in command of the first rank of Miami. Yeah, but he's a great knight. He's a great knight. He's a great knight. He's a paragon of chivalry. And that counts for more than being able to see. I was going to say being able to see is the absolute. No, being a paragon of chivalry is much more important. Well, we'll see how the battle works out for him.
但我绝不会让一个盲人去指挥军队的第一梯队。对，但他是个伟大的骑士。他是个伟大的骑士。他是个伟大的骑士。他是骑士精神的典范。这比看得见东西重要得多。本想说能看得见东西才是绝对的……不，成为骑士精神的典范要重要得多。好吧，我们拭目以待这场战斗对他的结果如何。
We'll see how it goes. Then the second division is under the command of Philip's brother, who is a guy called the Count of Alençon. So Alençon is a fiefdom in Normandy that traditionally is awarded to the kind of second-ranking royal in the French family. So that's the marker of the Count of Alençon's status. And the rearguard is commanded by Philip VI himself. So the Genoese longbowmen advance to get within reach of of the
我们拭目以待。接着，第二梯队由腓力的弟弟指挥，也就是阿朗松伯爵（Count of Alençon）。所以阿朗松是诺曼底的一个封地，传统上被授予法兰西王室里地位居于第二位的皇室成员。这就是阿朗松伯爵地位的标志。后卫部队由腓力六世亲自指挥。热那亚长弓手（应为弩手）向前推进，希望进入射程，
english as they hope and it starts to rain and this is a disaster because it means that the cords on their bows start to slacken but what about the longbowmen surely their do their strings not slacken as well no because they've prepared for it and also of course the range of the longbow is much greater than the range of the crossbow. So basically, the Genoese, without their shields, they can't fire arrows. They're not within range of the English. They get absolutely murdered.
能够够到英格兰人，这时天开始下雨了，这简直是一场灾难，因为这意味着他们弓上的弦开始松弛了。但是长弓手呢？难道他们的弓弦就不会松弛吗？不，因为他们做好了准备，而且当然，长弓的射程比弩的射程要远得多。所以基本上，热那亚人没有了盾牌，无法射箭。他们根本够不到英格兰人。他们遭到了绝对的屠杀。
And their commander can't see. Their commander can't see, exactly. Exactly. And so all the knights who are on their horses under the command of the Comte d'Alessandre behind are seeing that the Genoese are being useless. They not don't seem to be firing lots of them are starting to run away and this rumor goes around that they are that they're cowards or that they're traitors you know that they're in the pay of the english and the the count of alanson basically gets fed
而且他们的指挥官看不见。他们的指挥官看不见，正是如此。没错。因此，在阿朗松伯爵指挥下骑着马列阵在后面的所有骑士看到热那亚人毫无用处。他们似乎不仅不射箭，许多人还开始逃跑，于是谣言四起，说他们是懦夫，或者是叛徒，你知道的，说他们是被英格兰人收买的。阿朗松伯爵基本上对此忍无可忍，
up with it draws his sword um says they're all cowards let's let's ride them down um philip behind him gets terribly excited starts yelling in a loud voice kill them kill this riffraff kill them all kill the riffraff they're doing nothing it's such a french thing to shout isn't it the battle starts going badly and and basically saying you know they're absolutely useless they're in our way trampleample them down. And so the whole of the French cavalry starts careering across the battlefield, galloping down the... At their own troops. Well, they're Genoese, so they're expendable. And they're just, you know, they're archers.
拔出剑来，说他们都是懦夫，让我们把他们踩在脚下。他身后的腓力也变得极度兴奋，大声吼道：“杀了他们！杀了这群下三滥！把他们全杀了！杀了这些废物，他们什么都没用，挡了我们的路，把他们踩过去！”所以整个法兰西骑兵开始在战场上横冲直撞，践踏着……朝着他们自己的军队冲去。好吧，他们是热那亚人，所以是可以牺牲的。他们只是……你知道的，他们只是弓箭手。
So that's... Poor tactics, Tom, I have to say. And Edward has brought so many arrows that the arrow rain just keeps falling and falling and falling. And the French discover, as the Scottish knights had discovered earlier at Halladon Hill, that these are arrows that can penetrate their armor. And, you know, they are, horses are collapsing, knights are being horribly wounded or killed. There's a brilliant description by one of the French chroniclers who says that they were tumbling over each other like a vast litter of pigs. So kind of crashing down on top of each other. But some of them do get through.
所以这就……汤姆，我不得不说，这是糟糕的战术。爱德华带了如此多的箭矢，以至于箭雨不断地倾泻而下。法兰西人发现，正如苏格兰骑士早些时候在哈利登山所发现的那样，这些箭能够穿透他们的盔甲。而且，你知道的，战马纷纷倒毙，骑士们受到可怕的伤亡。法国编年史家有一段精彩的描述，说他们像一大窝猪一样一个接一个地滚倒在地。也就是说，彼此重叠着摔倒。但他们当中确实有些人冲了过来。
And of course, they attack the front English line, which is commanded by the Prince of Wales. Yeah. He's only 16, but he's already much taller than anybody else. He's a very physically prepossessing looking chap. And so he becomes the focus of the French attacks. At one point, his standard is dropped. It gets picked back up again. Messages go, you know, are sent by Sir Thomas Holland, who's there trying to look after the Prince of Wales, to Edward III saying, you know, could you send some reinforcements? And this is where Edward III
当然，他们攻击了由威尔士亲王指挥的英格兰前线。是的。他才16岁，但已经比其他任何人都高大得多了。他是一个外表极具威严的小伙子。因此，他成了法兰西人攻击的焦点。有那么一刻，他的战旗倒了。旗帜又被重新扶了起来。托马斯·霍兰德爵士当时正在那里试图照顾威尔士亲王，他派人给爱德华三世带话，说：“你能不能派点援兵？”就在这时，爱德华三世
delivers one of the most famous lines delivered by any English king, where he turns down this request and says, let the boy win his spurs. Do you know, I remember doing this at school when I was about 10 and that line, I loved, I mean, I loved the Battle of Crecy, but that line, the let the boy win his spurs, I just thought that was absolutely tremendous. It is. Everybody comes out so well from that. Yeah. And as we've always said, we're a very patriotic podcast, so we're going to enjoy that. So the French keep attacking and attacking and they keep getting wiped out and things get so bad that it's obvious they're going to lose. And at this point, John of Bohemia, that paragon of chivalry, decides that he's let France down, he's let Philip VI down, but worst of all, he's let himself down.
说出了任何英格兰国王所说过的最著名的台词之一，他拒绝了这个请求，并说道：“让这孩子自己赢得金马刺吧。”你知道，我大约10岁在学校里学到这个时，我爱极了那句话——我的意思是，我热爱克雷西战役，但“让这孩子自己赢得金马刺”那句话，我简直觉得太震撼了。确实如此。每个人在这场战役中都表现得极其出色。是的。正如我们一直所说的那样，我们是一个非常爱国的播客，所以我们会很享受这一点。因此法兰西人不断发起进攻，却又不断被全歼，局势变得如此糟糕，以至于他们显然要输了。就在这时，波希米亚的约翰，那个骑士精神的典范，认为他让法兰西失望了，让腓力六世失望了，但最糟糕的是，他让自己失望了。
He's absolutely let Bohemia down. And so he orders his squire to basically point him in the direction of the battle. And he just charges in. Is he even going the right way? How does he know? Well, you can hear the sound. So he charges into the melee, waving his sword around. And that's the end of him.
他绝对让波希米亚失望了。于是他命令他的随从指引他朝战场的方向走去。然后他径直冲了进去。他甚至走对了方向吗？他怎么知道的？好吧，你能听到声音。所以他挥舞着宝剑冲入了混战之中。那就是他的结局。
Oh, he's killed. Meanwhile, Philip VI gets struck in the face with an arrow. He has to be led away. The Aurorflame is left trampled in the mud. It's an absolute, it is exactly what Edward had wanted. It is a killing field. And as the sun sinks beneath the West, darkness spreads over the battlefield, sounds of screams of the dying and the wounded.
哦，他阵亡了。与此同时，腓力六世的面部被一支箭射中。他不得不被人搀扶着离开。弗拉姆军旗被践踏在泥土中。这绝对是一场杀戮场，完全如爱德华所愿。随着太阳沉入西方，黑暗笼罩了战场，空气中回荡着垂死者和受伤者的尖叫声。
Edward orders a great windmill on the hill to be filled with brushwood and set on fire so that the English will have a focus, but also they can see the scale of the victory that they've won. Tom, why on earth did Gibson waste his energy with Braveheart? I don't know. This would be a tremendous film, wouldn't it? And Edward comes and finds the Prince of Wales and embraces him and declares, Fair son, God save you. You are my good son and you have acquitted yourself nobly today. You are worthy to keep a realm. And the Prince of Wales has been given the ostrich feather crest of the fallen king of Bohemia. Ich dien, I serve.
爱德华下令将山上的一个大风车塞满灌木丛并点燃，这样英格兰人既能有一个集结的焦点，也能看清他们所取得的胜利的规模。汤姆，吉布森为什么要在《勇敢的心》上浪费精力呢？我不知道。这将会是一部震撼人心的电影，对吧？爱德华走过来找到了威尔士亲王，拥抱了他并宣告：“好孩子，上帝保佑你。你是我的好儿子，你今天表现得非常高贵。你配得上守护一个王国。”威尔士亲王得到了阵亡的波希米亚国王的鸵鸟羽毛冠饰。其座右铭为“Ich dien”，意即“我服务”。
And he gives it to Edward, and Edward gives it back to the Prince of Wales. And that's why the Prince of Wales to this day has the feathers. Has the ostrich feathers. And that motto, Ich dien. Exactly so. Exactly so. So all very stirring.
他把它送给了爱德华，而爱德华又把它还给了威尔士亲王。这就是为什么直到今天威尔士亲王依然拥有这些羽毛。拥有那些鸵鸟羽毛。还有那个座右铭，“Ich dien”。正是如此。确实如此。所以这一切都非常激动人心。
In the morning, a fresh contingent of French come up, get wiped out. So that's even more who've been wiped out. And the French casualties are stupefying. I mean, thousands and thousands are dead. King of Bohemia is dead. 11 princes are dead. The Count of Flanders is dead. The Count of Alençon, who had led the disastrous charge, is dead. An archbishop is dead. English casualties, 300 men. God, this is brilliant. This is one of the best episodes we've ever done, Tom. And so I mentioned about the similarities with Trafalgar.
到了早晨，一支新鲜的法军部队赶到，随即被全歼。所以这意味着更多的人被消灭了。法军的伤亡数字简直令人震惊。我的意思是，成千上万的人死去了。波希米亚国王死了。11位王子死了。佛兰德斯伯爵死了。导致了灾难性冲锋的阿朗松伯爵死了。一位大主教死了。英格兰方面的伤亡：300人。天哪，这太精彩了。这是我们做过的最好的剧集之一，汤姆。所以我刚才提到了它与特拉法加海战的相似之处。
Ian Mortimer in his book, Perfect King, about Edward III, writes that the importance of the Battle of Crecy cannot be exaggerated. It was the first major battle between two well-resourced martial kingdoms in which victory was obtained by projectile weaponry rather than hand-to-hand fighting. In that sense, it marks the advent of modern warfare, which is a very kind of striking claim to make. But, you know, in the sense that from now on,
伊恩·莫蒂默（Ian Mortimer）在他的关于爱德华三世的书《完美国王》中写道：“克雷西战役的重要性怎么高估都不为过。这是两个资源丰富的尚武王国之间的第一次重大战役，胜利不是靠近身肉搏，而是靠抛射武器取得的。”从这个意义上说，它标志着现代战争的诞生，这是一个非常引人注目的说法。但是，你知道的，从现在开始的意义上来说，
basically it will be first longbowmen, then, you know, rifles and muskets and rifles and so on. So, I mean, it's kind of interesting. It's a brilliant demonstration of the importance of technology, isn't it? I mean, because basically the English are grossly outnumber brilliant demonstration of the importance of technology, isn't it? I mean, because basically, the English are grossly outnumbered. They win because of technology, you know, strategy, that sort of, rather than martial, I mean, ironically, given that we remember Cressy for kind of martial valour
基本上首先是长弓手，然后是……你知道的，步枪、滑膛枪和步枪等等。所以，我的意思是，这挺有意思的。这完美展示了技术的重要性，不是吗？我的意思是，因为基本上英格兰人在人数上处于绝对劣势。技术的重要性得到了完美的展示，不是吗？我的意思是，因为基本上英格兰人在人数上处于绝对劣势。他们之所以能赢，是因为技术，你知道的，战略之类的，而不是尚武精神——讽刺的是，鉴于我们铭记克雷西战役是因为那种尚武的勇气
and the heroism of the Prince of Wales and whatnot. It's actually not won by that, is it? Right. And so that's kind of the immediate impact of this, is that firstly, it is a demonstration by Edward III that his chivalric prowess is now greater than that of France. So that's an incredible bragging right. But you're right that the victory has basically been won by archers,
以及威尔士亲王的英雄主义之类的事情。实际上它并不是靠这个赢的，对吧？没错。所以这就是这带来的直接影响，首先，这是爱德华三世的一次展示，证明他现在的骑士风范已经超越了法国。这真是一个令人难以置信的吹嘘资本。但你说得对，这场胜利基本上是靠弓箭手赢得的，
by yeomen and peasants, not by knights. And Edward's genius really is to kind of fuse the stories that are told about the Prince of Wales with the achievements of the Longbowmen. And that over the next two decades will be a kind of very potent combination, a kind of very potent myth. This idea that knights and yeomen in the English armies are fused in a common sense of purpose. But the challenge for Edward obviously is now he's won his battle. What next? I mean, he hasn't become king of France. So what's he going to do?
靠的是自耕农和农民，而不是骑士。爱德华的天才之处其实在于，他将围绕威尔士亲王的故事与长弓手的成就融合在了一起。在接下来的二十年里，这将成为一种极具潜力的组合，一种非常强效的神话。这种理念即英格兰军队中的骑士和自耕农在一个共同的目标感中融为一体。但对爱德华来说，显而易见的挑战是，现在他赢得了这场战役。接下来怎么办？我的意思是，他并没有成为法兰西国王。所以他打算做什么？
So his plan is to win. In the aftermath of this, he wants to win a permanent foothold in northern France because the problem is landing on Normandy beaches is always risky. So he has targeted a place called Calais, which is very, very well protected. It's kind of surrounded by marshes, very high walls, commanded by one of France's best soldiers, a man called Jean de Vienne. But Edward is determined to seize it. It's a very, very long siege. It requires all his administrative ability, his strategic ability, his organizational ability. It involves blockades, naval blockades,
所以他的计划是彻底获胜。在这场战役之后，他想要在法国北部获得一个永久的立足点，因为问题在于在诺曼底海滩登陆总是充满风险。因此他把目标锁定了一个叫做加来（Calais）的地方，那里的防卫非常非常严密。它四周环绕着沼泽，城墙非常高，由法国最优秀的士兵之一、一个名叫让·德·维埃纳（Jean de Vienne）的人统帅。但爱德华决心夺取它。这是一场非常非常漫长的围城战。这需要他所有的行政能力、战略能力、组织能力。它涉及封锁，海军封锁，
the transfer of troops and foods and supplies and arrows and all this kind of thing. So incredible figures between July 1346 when he starts the siege and September 1347 when Calais finally surrenders. England's port supplied Edward with 853 ships manned by 23,907 seamen. Very precise figures reflective of the kind of the paper trail. You need some kind of bureaucracy to do all this. And while this siege is going on, there are two further incredible triumphs that set the seal on this Annus Mirabilis. The first is that on the 17th of October, David II, the Scottish king, who in obedience
军队、食物、补给品和箭矢的调运等等。从1346年7他开始围城到1347年9月加来最终投降，期间的数据令人难以置信。英格兰的港口为爱德华提供了853艘船只，配有23907名水手。这些极其精确的数字反映了纸面文书的痕迹。做这一切你需要某种官僚体制。正当这场围城战进行的同时，还有另外两场令人难以置信的伟大胜利，为这个“奇迹之年”（Annus Mirabilis）画上了圆满的句号。首先是10月17日，苏格兰国王大卫二世——他遵照
to the old alliance has invaded England, is met at a place called Neville's Cross, an English army led by two lords, Neville and Percy, who in the 14th century and 15th century particularly will become massive players. Yeah. The great Northern magnates. The great Northern magnates and the Archbishop of York. And the Archbishop of York has taken with him the banner of St. Cuthbert from Durham Cathedral.bert, you know, he gets in behind England because the Scots are absolutely wiped out
老同盟的协议入侵了英格兰——在尼维尔十字（Neville's Cross）遭遇了一支由两位贵族领主（内维尔和珀西——他们在14世纪和15世纪将成为举足轻重的大人物）率领的英格兰军队。对。伟大的北方豪强。伟大的北方豪强，以及约克大主教。约克大主教甚至把来自达勒姆大教堂的圣库斯伯特（St. Cuthbert）的旗帜带在了身边。伯特，你知道的，他深入英格兰后方，因为苏格兰人被彻底消灭了，
and David is taken prisoner. He's found hiding under a bridge and brought to London. They should have just stopped history then, shouldn't they? Well, no, because there's more to come, Dominic, there's more to come. Because England had won.
大卫被俘了。人们发现他躲在一座桥下，然后被押送到伦敦。他们当时就该给历史画上句号的，不是吗？嗯，不，因为还有更多好戏在后头，多米尼克，还有更多。因为英格兰已经赢了。
So the following year, 20th of June, so in 1347, Charles de Blois, who is Philip VI's candidate to be Duke of Brittany, is defeated and he's taken prisoner and taken to England. So the prisoners are stacking up. Philip VI, meanwhile, has attempted to relieve Calais, can't do it, so retreats. So that's another humiliation for him. And on the 4th of August, 1347, Calais surrenders. And it's an unconditional surrender.
所以在第二年，即1347年6月20日，查尔斯·德·布卢瓦（Charles de Blois）——他是腓力六世心目中的布列塔尼公爵人选——被击败并被俘，押往英格兰。所以俘虏越积越多。与此同时，腓力六世试图解加来之围，却无能为力，只能撤退。这对他的又一次羞辱。在1347年8月4日，加来投降了。这是一场无条件投降。
And in token of this, Jean de Vienne and six of the burghers of Calais. So not burghers as in, you know, Big Macs, but people who are kind of leading merchants, that kind of thing. They come out from Calais, they're bareheaded. Jean de Vienne is holding his sword backwards as a kind of symbol of his acknowledgement that he's been defeated. So he's riding out. Behind him, walking barefoot, come the burghers, barefoot, only wearing their shirts. And they're wearing halters around their neck, which is kind of symbolic of their acknowledgement that Edward has the right to hang them. Edward says he is going to hang them. His wife, his queen, Philippa, begs for mercy. And this is what queens do in the Middle Ages. Kings are very stern. Queens beg for mercy. The king then gives in to the queen and everyone is satisfied. So Edward has simultaneously been able to demonstrate that he's a figure of terrifying determination, but also that thanks to Queen Philippa, he's going to show mercy. So he lets the people of Calais live, but he expels them because his aim is to reestablish Calais as an English city. So people
作为投降的象征，让·德·维埃纳和加来六位显贵的市民——不是指“巨无霸”汉堡包的那种市民，而是指那些主要商人之类的人——他们从加来走了出来，没有戴帽子。让·德·维埃纳倒握着他的剑，以此象征他承认自己已经战败。所以他骑着马出来了。在他身后，市民们赤脚走着，赤着脚，身上只穿着衬衫。他们的脖子上套着绞索，这象征着他们承认爱德华有权将他们绞死。爱德华说他要将他们绞死。他的妻子，王后菲利帕，恳求宽恕。这就是中世纪王后们所做的事。国王非常严厉。王后则恳求宽恕。于是国王向王后妥协了，皆大欢喜。因此，爱德华既成功地展现了自己令人畏惧的决心，又通过菲利帕王后展现了仁慈。所以他放过了加来的百姓，但把他们驱逐了，因为他的目标是将加来重新建立为一座英格兰城市。所以来自英格兰的
from England are given all kinds of trade deals and rights to live in Calais. And so there's a massive population transfer. So Calais is to be an English city. It is given a garrison that is the largest concentration of troops in any urban settlement in Europe. So it's an absolute triumph. The scale of English success is everything that Edward could have wanted. And so, of course, in the autumn of 1347, he is looking forward to continued successes, perhaps over the winter, perhaps into 1348. But Dominic, something intervenes. So am I right in thinking, Tom, that hundreds of miles to the south, in Messina in Sicily, a Genoese ship lands at pretty much that exact moment. Pretty much as Calais is falling. As Calais is falling.
人们得到了各种贸易特权和在加来居住的权利。因此这里发生了一场大规模的人口迁移。所以加来将成为一座英格兰城市。它获得了一支驻军，这是欧洲任何城市定居点中最大规模的军队集结。所以这是一场绝对的胜利。英格兰胜利的规模满足了爱德华所有的愿望。因此，当然，在1347年的秋天，他正期待着接下来的胜利，也许是在冬天，也许延续到1348年。但是，多米尼克，有什么事情插了进来。那么我是不是可以这样认为，汤姆，在几百英里以南的西西里墨西拿，几乎就在那个确切的时刻，一艘热那亚船只靠岸了。几乎就在加来陷落的同时。就在加来陷落的时候。
And on board the ship, some of the sailors are carrying an unknown and utterly deadly disease. Marked by black buboes under the armpits. I mean, that really, if this was a, you know, we were joking about it being Game of Thrones or being a Hollywood film. But that is the ultimate twist, isn't it? That you can just see the picture fading on the scenes of celebration and then a kind of epilogue or a post-credits scene of this. The Black Death. The ship arriving. The Black Death is coming.
在这艘船上，有些水手携带了一种未知且极其致命的疾病。其特征是胳肢窝下长出了黑色的腹股沟淋巴结肿块。我的意思是，如果这是一部……我们之前开玩笑说这是《权力的游戏》或者好莱坞电影。但这绝对是终极转折，不是吗？你几乎可以看到镜头在庆祝的场面上渐渐淡出，然后是一个尾声或者演职员表后的彩蛋场景。黑死病。船只靠岸了。黑死病正在袭来。
And that changes everything. And actually, I would love to hear what happens next, but we're not going to, are we? We're going to wait till next week. We are. For those of you who are members of the rest is history club i know people love hearing this again and again so i think we should give people what they want tom um that's what we want for those of you who are members of the rest is history club you can find out what happens next
而这改变了一切。实际上，我很想听听接下来会发生什么，但我们不会讲了，对吧？我们要等到下周。是的。对于那些加入“历史就是一切”俱乐部（The Rest Is History Club）的会员们，我知道大家喜欢一遍又一遍地听这些，所以我认为我们应该满足大家的愿望，汤姆……这就是我们想要的，对于那些加入“历史就是一切”俱乐部的会员们，你们可以去了解接下来会发生什么。
does the black death make a difference to the course of the hundred years war spoiler alert it changes everything you can hear that right now if you're not a member of the rest is history club and you could of course join up at rest is history pod.com but if you don't want to you'll have to wait till next week and that's so and and next week it's not just about the black death it's also about the black prince the black death and the black prince very good tom i like like that So we will be joining you next week With The Black Death and The Black Prince And the next, and most importantly
黑死病对百年战争的进程有什么影响吗？剧透警告：它改变了一切。如果你还不是“历史就是一切”俱乐部的会员，你现在就可以听到这个内容，当然你也可以在 restishistorypod.com 注册加入。但如果你不想注册，你就得等到下周了。所以，下周的内容不仅关于黑死病，还关于黑太子。黑死病与黑太子。非常棒，汤姆，我喜欢这个。所以我们下周将和大家一起探讨《黑死病与黑太子》以及接下来的，最重要的是
The next exciting reading From Sir Nigel And when I tell you that this is the moment Where Nigel meets Raoul de la Roche, Pierre de Bras A free vavasor of the noble Count of Toulouse You will know how exciting that is
来自《奈杰尔爵士》（Sir Nigel）的下一段精彩朗读。当我告诉你这是奈杰尔遇见拉乌尔·德·拉·罗什（Raoul de la Roche）、皮埃尔·德·布拉斯（Pierre de Bras）——图卢兹贵族伯爵手下的自由附庸骑士——的时刻时，你就会知道这有多么令人兴奋。
a very debonair man Tom and he and Nigel become fast friends as you will remember from your childhood reading, so there's lots to look forward to next week and on that bombshell we will say au revoir Au revoir Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History.
一个非常温文尔雅的人，汤姆，他和奈杰尔成了至交好友，正如你童年阅读中所记得的那样，所以下周有很多值得期待的内容，伴随着这个重磅消息，我们要说一声再见（au revoir）。再见（au revoir）。感谢收听《历史就是一切》。
For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有关更多精彩节目、抢先收听、无广告体验以及我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。